I’M JACKIE IBANEZ GREAT NOW BACK
TO "THE GREG GUTFELD SHOW."
♪
GREG: IT’S BEEN ALMOST A YEAR
AND THIS PANDEMIC AND I CAN FIND
MYSELF SAYING, PLEASE GOD MAKE
THIS -- DO WE NEED A LUCKY CHARM
TO SCHEDULE A SHOT IN THE ARM?
WE SPENT THE LAST FEW WEEKS
FRUITLESSLY SEARCHING ON LINE
FOR A VACCINE APPOINTMENT YOU
ARE NOT ALONE.
AFTER THE DISTRIBUTION PLAN TO
THE LINE FOR CABBAGE IN THE OLD
SOVIET UNION.
THERE’S ALWAYS A LINE FOR
CABBAGE.
TO GET AN APPOINTMENT MOST ARE
SITTING AT THE SITTING AT THEIR
COMPUTER WITH WAS SEVERAL LINKS
OPEN CONSTANTLY GETTING
REFRESHED HOPING APPOINTMENTS
WILL POP UP SOMEWHERE SOMETIME
BEFORE THE END OF TIME.
IF YOU’RE NOT INTERNET SAVVY YOU
ARE OUT OF LUCK.
MIKE LAMES YOU KNOW WHO.
>> MY PREDECESSOR WAS VERY LONG
ABOUT IT AND DID NOT DO HIS JOB
AND GETTING READY FOR THE
MASSIVE CHALLENGE OF VACCINATING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS.
HE DIDN’T ORDER ENOUGH VACCINES.
HE DIDN’T MOBILIZE ENOUGH PEOPLE
TO ADMINISTER THE SHOT.
HE HE DIDN’T SET UP THE FEDERAL
VACCINE CENTER WHERE ELIGIBLE
PEOPLE COULD GO AND GET THEIR
SHOTS.
GREG: HE FORGOT THESE THESE
PRESENT HAPPENED WHITE HAS A
BILL OF SIX OR MILLION VACCINES
BY JULY SO UNTIL THEN WE’LL KEEP
ON CLICKING.
ONE GUY NEW YORK FOUND A WAY TO
STREAMLINE INFORMATION FROM ALL
THOSE WEB SITES INTO ONE PLACE.
HE CALLS IT TURBO BACK AND IT’S
UP DATED CONSTANTLY.
THE PRIVATE SECTOR BUILDS A
BETTER PRODUCT WHICH BRINGS US
TO BIG GOVERNMENT.
REMEMBER JOE BIDEN’S COMMITMENT
TO GET KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL IN
HIS FIRST 100 DAYS?
>> I MADE A COMMITMENT THAT WE
TRIED TO GET K-8 BACK TO SCHOOL
BY THE END OF THIS 100 DAYS.
>> WILL ALSO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO SAFELY REOPEN THE
MAJORITY OF OUR K-8 SCHOOLS BY
THE END OF THE FIRST 100 DAYS.
GREG: THAT COMMITMENT IS TURNED
INTO A ONE DAY A WEEK IN APRIL.
>> THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS
DURING TRANSITION ABOUT
REOPENING SCHOOLS WITH THEM 100
DAYS WHY DIDN’T HE MENTION IN
SMALL.
THAT WOULD BE FOR ONE WEEK?
>> AGAIN THE PRESIDENT MADE --
SO THE GOAL OF REOPENING THE
MAJORITY OF SCHOOLS WITHIN 100
DAYS AND I ANSWER THE QUESTION.
THAT IS NOT THE FEELING.
THAT IS THE BAR WHERE TRENDY
LEAP OVER AND ACHIEVE.
GREG: A SALAMANDER COULD LEAP
OVER THAT WORD.
I CAN WALK UNDER THAT ARE.
JOE WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY FOR
YOURSELF?
>> AND OUT PRESIDENT BIDEN ON
REOPENING SCHOOLS.
>> THAT’S RIGHT, HE ONE DAY
GOING TO SCHOOL.
TUESDAY THROUGH FRIDAY HE STAY
HOME AND DO ZOOM BUT CLASSES.
THESE KIDS LOVE ZOOM BY.
THAT WILL SAVE SOME MONEY RIGHT
THERE, SIX OR SEVEN UNDER BUCS
RELEASE PREFIGURE MONEY FOR
SHOES.
ALL KINDS OF SHOES, CASHEWS.
THAT’S RIGHT COME IF THE SHOE
FITS A GODMOTHER SAYS YOU CAN GO
TO THE BALL.
WALK A MILE IN A MAN’S SHOES, I
WILL MAKE YOU A JUDGE.
GREG: TYRUS I CAN’T FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GET A VACCINE.
>> I HAVE NO CLUE.
GREG: WE ARE NOT IMPORTANT
ENOUGH.
>> I DON’T EVEN KNOW WHICH WAY
TO GO.
GREG: EVEN PEOPLE WHO NEED IT
CAN’T GET IT.
>> I THINK IT GOES BACK TO, I
KEEP SAYING TO MYSELF OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THE ADULTS ARE IN THE
ROOM.
THE ONLY THING WE HAVE SEEN AT A
HIGH LEVEL IS EXECUTIVE ORDERS
AND THE COMPLETE DISAPPEARANCE
OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
I GET IT, THINGS ARE MORE
QUIETER WE DON’T HAVE THE TWEETS
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE WE DON’T
HAVE ANY MORE?
ACCOUNTABILITY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD NO PROBLEM
POINTING OUT WHO IS NOT DOING
THEIR JOB AND NOW WE ARE BACK IN
THE SHADOWS.
EVERYBODY SAYS OH WHAT WE MEANT
WAS THE BAR.
THAT’S NOT EVEN LIKE A CHALK
LINE ON THE GROUND.
ONE DAY A WEEK?
I HAVE CHILDREN.
I HAVE A LOT.
SOME GO TO PRIVATE SCHOOL AND
SOME GO TO PUBLIC SCHOOL.
MY KIDS ON PRIVATE SCHOOL ARE
FULL DAY, FIVE DAYS A WEEK HUMAN
SOMETHING HAPPENS AND MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS.
PUBLIC SCHOOL, THEY RUN VIRTUAL
LEARNING IN VIRTUAL LEARNING IS
BRUTAL BECAUSE YOU CANNOT MAKE A
9-YEAR-OLD SIT IN FRONT OF A
ZOOM CLASS WITH A TEXAN
CHICLET -- TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES THAT THEY HAVE THESE
DAYS.
ONE KID LITERALLY RODE WROTE
BUFFERING AS HIS NAME SO THE
TEACHER IS LIKE OH IT’S STILL
LOADING.
THEY ARE THAT CLEVER.
MY DAUGHTER TOOK A SELFIE OF
HERSELF AND POSITIONED IN FRONT
OF THE CAMERA LIKE THIS.
AND WAS OFF PLAYING WITH BARBIE
DOLLS.
>> IMAGINE IF NO ONE ASKED HER
WHAT SHE MEANT BY OPENING
SCHOOLS.
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL ONE DAY A
WEEK DOES NOT MEAN SCHOOLS ARE
REOPENED ANYMORE THAN SEEING
YOUR EX-MANGER ACT TOGETHER.
LIKE A CHEAP SUBSTITUTE AND A
JOKE.
YES WE ARE REOPENING.
REOPENING?
>> AS A FORMER TEACHER IT’S
COMPLETELY INSANE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE ONE DAY A WEEK.
IT’S GOING TO BE LIKE RECESS.
THEY ARE ALL EXCITED TO SEE EACH
OTHER AND THEN THEY DON’T DO
MANY HAVE TO MAKE UP.
IT’S TOO MUCH INCONSISTENCY FOR
KIDS.
THEY HAVE NO ACCOUNTABILITY AND
MORE.
NOT THEIR FAULT.
GREG: ALL RIGHT JOE, MY ANALOGY
FOR ME IS THAT I’M LIKE GROUP
NINE AND BOARDING A PLANE FOR
THIS VACCINE.
IMC 54J.
>> THAT MUST BE HARD FOR YOU.
YOU AREN’T USED TO THAT.
GREG: I’M NOT USED TO THAT.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THIS?
>> I THINK ONE DAY A WEEK ISN’T
A FULL WEEK OF SCHOOL IN THE
SAME ROLE WHERE TWO WEEKS
FLATTENS THE CURVE.
IT’S EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT DOES THE
EASY PART HARD.
THE HARD PART IS GETTING THE
VACCINE AND THE EASY PART SHOULD
BE GETTING PEOPLE TO GET IT,
HAVING A CLEAR PROCESS FOR WHO
GETS IT WHEN AND IT DOESN’T SEEM
TO HAPPEN LIKE THAT.
THAT’S WHAT WORRIES ME ABOUT
PROFESSIONAL HEALTH CARE.
MOST CONSERVATIVES ARE WILLING
TO HAVE THE CONVERSATION THAT WE
NEED TO GET EVERYONE COVERED
WITH HEALTH CARE IN SOME FASHION
BUT SHOULD IT BE JUST THE
GOVERNMENT?
THEN WE WILL NEED MORE
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THERE HAS TO
BE SOME SORT OF COMPETITION.
>> IN THE WEB SITE TO A SUPER
CONFUSING WEB SITE.
THE GOVERNMENT IS THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY TO DO THINGS.
GREG: THEY COULD HAVE DONE THAT
FOR 50 BILLION THOUGH.
IT WOULD JAM UP.
SINCE THEY’LL PROBABLY SPEND A
LOT FOR THAN 50,000.
GREG: THEY CAN MAKE A WEB SITE
FOR 50 BILLION THAT JAMS UP A
PRINTER.
HER NUMBER THOSE?
>> IT RUNS OFF OF COMMODORE 64.
GOVERNMENT PORTAL.
IT’S JUST THE NATURE OF
GOVERNMENT AND BUREAUCRACY SOME
POLITICIANS COME IN AND TAKE
SOMETHING THAT IS CRYSTAL CLEAR
AND OBVIOUS AND MAKE IT
INEFFICIENT AND NONFUNCTIONING.
KIDS DO NOT TRANSMIT EVEN IF
THEY HAVE THE VIRUS THEY DO NOT
TRANSMIT THE VIRUS LIKE ADULTS
DO.
THEY ARE LESS LIKELY TO GET VERY